[Music]
what's up guys we are back and we're
going to be talking about the iphone 13
pro pro max today but we're doing a
little something different than a normal
review because apple's of course touting
the camera system as the big thing this
year so instead of just walking around
taking you know street photography stuff
and just kind of showing to you on
youtube we thought we'd do something
different i'm with barry who's a
commercial photographer
and he's also known as motographer here
in singapore takes some badass photos of
motorcycles some great composites so we
thought we'd come into his studio today
and we are going to test out the iphone
13 pro max we're going to be shooting
his awesome hayabusa
and then
we're going to actually print it out
yeah a2 format yes and we're going to
see how good the resolution is on these
new cameras
and you're gonna be doing some composite
stuff as well yes i will be doing some
composite and some special effects after
the shoot is done okay so we're gonna
see that work um and by the way we're
not paid or sponsor this we have no idea
if this is gonna work or not this could
fall flat it could be great i mean
when's the last time you used an iphone
uh the last iphone i used was iphone 11
pro max that's all and um i find the
camera just all right only so i haven't
yet tried the 12 and 13 yet okay well
with 12 obviously came raw format so you
can shoot raw with your images and of
course now with the 13 you've got these
baked in profiles that you can also use
we'll talk more about that later on by
the way this entire review is shot on
the iphone 13 pro and we'll be showing
you some of the cinematic modes all that
kind of fun stuff but also just showing
you the quality of the video throughout
this entire thing audio of courses we're
using audio going into an uh a zoom
recorder because we didn't have the
right cables to plug into the iphone
unfortunately today but
it's great audio nonetheless all right
barry so uh let's light this place up
we've got spotty here who's your light
model uh yes yeah so spotty actually
sits on the motorcycle
and he stays there yeah yeah so we'll
try some of the macro the new features
with the new camera all right with matt
with a spotty's really uh good looking
face are you ready are you ready spotty
okay we're ready as well let's do it all
right okay so now we're going to do a
little bit of a macro shot here i'm
going to do this with my photo styles
and rich contrast first hey spotty hey
buddy yeah
now the camera automatically does click
in you don't have control over the macro
but
there you go buddy good boy good boy
okay now i'm gonna shoot in raw
yeah
i like shooting in raw more but then i'm
used to that with all the cameras that i
test
you do use the styles when you do shoot
in raw though it's only for jpeg
how does it look
very sharp very very sharp
that's really sharp
now you can't i mean i think it's about
uh 2cm or they're about so you can get
as close to your subject so you want to
crop in but the resolution is so good
that you can crop in and it still
maintains it it looks really really nice
so all right thanks spotty thank you are
you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so i'm going to try shooting
this in jpeg first
now i'll try doing a telephoto shot here
and then we'll do a wide
go back to the main now i'm using the if
you can see the profile on this i'm
using the rich contrast you can actually
adjust this if you want so you can bring
it down or up however you want it to be
and as it goes to a certain point it
will actually automatically change
so bring the contrast down
about 41
now we're gonna go into raw mode so raw
it's probably what we're gonna use for
printing just to kind of show the
quality of this
so a little bit wide here but we can
crop that
and then we'll go telephoto on it
and go ultra wide
spotty's inside the shot come on spotty
come over here come on
come on can we go down like that
i think this is where a lot of people
get confused from is that they when they
look at their monitor their phone screen
and that they see something pixelated
there they think oh or they see noise or
whatever it may be they think okay the
camera is not good or something is not
right but actually when you print the
image out it's really where you see how
good a camera system is and even a lens
for that matter how sharp it is in the
detail because our screens can only
resolve so much especially these
consumer grade screens right i mean if
you want to get a high caliber screen
that's thousands and thousands of
dollars it's a different ball game but
for what we're looking at you only get
you're only going to see so much so i'm
going to take photos with the iphone 12
pro max now
unfortunately we don't have the picture
styles with the 12 pro max or the 12 pro
that's only available for the a15 bionic
so
i'll try with jpeg here
thanks spotty
that tastes really good today
i'm gonna use the uh main camera here
jpeg and then shoot some raw
file size is around 27 to 28 megabytes
they're about so you're getting
definitely get a lot more information
i'll do some telephoto here
and then
shoot the rear of the motorcycle and
then we're going to go wide on this as
well
all right that's shooting in raw
let's take a look at
the detail on the wide
[Music]
i would say you know
first impressions the 13 pro is slightly
better on the wide than the 12
but it's ever so slight again we have to
look this on you know look up on a
on a computer screen to see the
difference and we'll send over to barry
so we can take a look
but uh let's take a look at the
telephoto
i would say
telephoto is very very similar this is
quite sharp on the
on the 12 pro max it's quite sharp
so
i think you maybe will see more of a
difference with the wide angle than
anything else
but i mean the image quality looks
really good off the 12 pro max and the
12 pro so i mean here's the thing
um unless you need some of these
additional benefits if you're just going
to take some photos you're like look do
i do i have greater than 13 i'm only
taking photos once in a while et cetera
et cetera you know you might not need to
upgrade it just depends it really
depends on you your budget and do you
want the latest and greatest from apple
um because these images are still really
nice but when you put it onto a printer
like what barry has you're gonna see a
world of difference
in the image quality so i can't wait to
see what it looks like i'm going to pass
these images to barry he's going to do
his little magic crop it out a little
bit you know fine tune the image and
then we will get it printed and of
spotty who keeps licking me because i
taste really good today i guess i should
try myself maybe i should
i can see why he likes me okay yeah so
we're gonna go and capture one right now
we're gonna take a look at the jpegs
first you'll see the quality of jpegs
between the 12 pro max
and the 13 pro max
13 is on the left and the 12 is on the
right okay
so
one big difference you're going to
notice is of course the new styles i
actually added the rich contrast
to my image so you're going to notice
that the 13 is a little bit more
contrasty a little bit more punchier
than the 12 because unfortunately
without the 815 bionic chip you can't
get those photographic styles in it but
uh let's take a look at the quality of
it so i i find that the yeah the 12 have
a bit more detail
actually a bit by lesser contrast i
guess the contrast
uh it killed quite a lot here especially
at the radiator area yeah yeah at the
radiator you still see some but not as
much so yeah it's not in much that's all
okay jpeg yeah so what do we boost up
the shadows yeah let's uh check out at
the
wheel area
i push it up to 100 for both
okay
so actually the wheels on the 13 yeah
it's more is
actually
so jpeg yeah in jpeg but the iphone 12
seems to have more detail at the bricks
area yeah
well here is a little smudgy but i also
suspect it might be the contrast yeah it
could be the contrast the ball
but you know what i noticed is when you
push up the shadows on this 100 on the
12 it starts breaking up a little bit
yeah there's a lot more
yeah artifacts yeah a little like ag
yeah yeah this one is a bit more rounded
more smoother yeah so 13 is a little bit
more controlled on that yeah yeah
interesting with the 13 when you boost
up the shadows 100
with this rich contrast style to it it
holds relatively well
yeah it's not breaking apart correct
correct definitely the 12 because it's
more standard it's more neutral you're
going to see a lot more of that the
shadows the detail in the shadows
whereas with the rich contrast it's more
of a stylistic approach of course you
can adjust this inside the camera to be
less contrasty or more
um but it's just to kind of show the
difference between the two with styles i
mean it still maintains some decent
detail of course but again we're looking
at this at you know really punching in
yes if let's say uh for the for the
right for the jpeg we just add the
contrast a bit more yeah then a bit on
the to try to match this yeah it's
actually quite similar but instead of
doing any adjustments you know it comes
straight like that right let's do raw
for a wide angle yeah okay let's try
that out for white angle
here it is the wide angle
okay
so wow first difference is looks like
the 13 is slightly wider yes
you can see the left side of the counter
on the backdrop yeah it's way wider but
you know one thing i'm looking at this
right the 13 it's got a little bit more
distortion on the edges whereas the four
uh the 12 is a little bit more
straighter with the lights you know
looking at the lightest lights but it
has distortion at the center that's
right it's kind of like yeah it's
started out yeah yeah it's uh okay maybe
i just increased the brightness a bit so
it's much more clearer
yeah you can see that the wheels are
being pulled out right over here for the
12 but then for the 13 it is actually
more
um
yeah it's actually yeah
more
does not have much distortion but the
distortion is at the edge of the lens
yeah at the edge what i can see the most
obvious difference is the distortion
yeah yeah the distortion is like here
for the iphone 13 is center fine there
after that distort yeah well for the
iphone 12 is distort yeah
it's like a fish eye
kind of thing all right so apple's
improved the 13 for the wide-angle bit
yeah okay cool
fish is very good for portraits yes yes
yeah what else you would look like
yeah exactly
and you don't want to shoot an image of
somebody and they're looking bigger in
the middle yeah and distorted and you
don't want to be at the edge
so you want to see you want to have a
different size okay i'll be at the edge
telephoto all right the telephoto raw so
basically
okay yeah the the difference is the
telephoto lens
this is like the real telephoto on the
iphone 30 well the iphone 12 is still a
bit white yeah yeah
let me see 7.5 for the f2 f2
nine
for the 13. yeah so nine millimeter okay
yeah i think that's the difference yeah
it is and then
i would say looking at just about the
overall image quality i mean the 12
might seem a little bit brighter
but the
the tonality i like in the 13 a little
bit more i mean it's a little darker but
it seems to have like let's push it up a
bit to see the detail yeah
let's bring it up a bit
oh i think i just bring up the
brightness bring on the shadow a little
oh no like this yep yeah yeah yeah
somewhere there and still maintain still
holds yeah yeah
but uh and also the distortion as well
again yeah it's much better on the 13.
yeah you get more of that compression
that you normally get on a telephoto
lens you're getting that in the 13.
whereas the the 12 is just more like
yeah
so can actually you can see by the by
the tires
um this is and the tires
it is a little pull on the right right
yeah it's a little but it's very very
slight so yeah the round is slightly
oval well this one is really round yeah
it's actually very obvious on that but
let's see about the details on the
on the shadow for both
it looks more detailed on the on the 13.
yes sharper let me uh there's like eight
no no this one let me just bring this i
think oh because the brightness is
already up
yeah but even on the brake on the on the
disc the brake disc yes you can see
there's more details yeah you can see
that still on the 13 yeah yeah and also
at the edge the sharpness here is a
little smudgy yes on the iphone 12 right
the iphone 13 is much more okay yeah
okay cool now let's look at the standard
standard the main camera the main camera
main camera raw yeah they're really kind
of neck and neck when you look at the
detail it's really close i mean yeah i
would say the tonality is slightly
i think the highlights are more
controlled it seems to be on the 13.
like you know if you look at the brake
disc right there like you see that it's
a little bit brighter on the 12 versus
the 13. yes it looks more contrasty yes
on the
on the iphone 12 yeah yeah whereas the
13 is a little bit more yeah it's
controlled a little bit better on that
yeah the 13 has more details compared to
the 12
yeah
other than that okay let's see on the
highlights control i bring down the
highlights you can see this yeah let's
bring down the highlights from okay
actually not bad right yeah not bad not
bad actually uh both of them yeah quite
good let's see the shadow i just put
this back up
and the shadow
and for here okay i just put it both at
100 yep i would say
it's really close
yeah yeah quite close they're quite
close i would say
yeah because the 13 uh pro max images
slightly
slightly you know darker or i would say
less you know not as bright yes not as
bright as the 12 that you know when you
boost the shadows up to 100
you're still maintaining a lot of detail
inside of it it's not breaking apart yes
correct yeah all the details on the
on the edges yeah over here yeah even
though of course because this is a
standard so it will be a bit larger when
you zoom in sure but you can see that
this is more defined the the edge of the
tire yeah over here is a bit more
defined than this this is a bit smudgy
yeah let me see whether i can just close
up a bit this i think it's more obvious
yeah you can see that's why you can see
a line yes you find like this is blurred
yesterday yeah it's true so it's all
these small little details uh in the
standard lens okay let's see the
exhaust area okay here is actually quite
quite obvious
it is actually more sharper on the lines
yeah yeah this part
and i noticed that actually uh because
you are in the same
uh same uh distance yeah this one seems
to be a little wider but i think yeah
that's only about it i mean but then
again we're not put on tripod so i'm
using it myself so there could be a
little bit of allowance for that yeah
okay we bring up the shadows again sure
it looks better than 13. though the the
12 is looking a little bit washed out
yeah where the 13 is still holding up a
little bit better on that it is still
more defined in here
in the black area yeah
yeah here is uh the iphone 12 is like a
bit sluggish so iphone 13 actually has
improved a lot in the image quality yeah
but again for people out there just to
be realistic we're really pixel peeping
at this point in time i mean if you've
got a 12 pro or 12 pro max it still
takes fantastic images we're just really
comparing it to pixel peeping zooming in
like 100 to 200
on an image so um but you know some of
you out there love to do this and we do
this for camera reviews as well let's
take a look at a macro shot here all
right i'm spotty yeah spotty okay so for
the macro shot uh let me since there's
no macro on the 12 we can only do on the
13 here yeah okay so we see it okay and
let's go in
i just bring it bright a bit bring down
the highlights
wow
when i bring down the highlights is wow
you know you look at the detail yeah you
can see the detail on the bottom oh wow
see these 100
wow
and then you can see it did not smudge
the fur yeah yeah that's the part this
even the tiniest fur near his eyes yeah
yeah it's like you can see one line one
line online
yeah over here as well
i have to say i i think out of all the
new uh things that apple's put into the
camera system i think the macro will be
the one that people will use the most
and will be more impressed with out of
every yes the new camera sensors are
bigger you know and they've improved you
know the wide angle and the telephoto
but the macro capabilities are actually
really fun and you know in sometimes
when you need to shoot video or need to
shoot photography you need something
macro and you don't have that macro lens
this can come and help out in a pinch
you know yeah man so okay so what we'll
do is you take the standard photo from
the bike because we'll use that as the
main camera sensor then take a macro
shot of spotty yes we'll do a little
couple test prints and see what the
results are
all right all right so now we have
printed up some images from the iphone
13 pro max here an a4 and a2 size
and barry
what are your thoughts man go for it
yeah well i feel that the
resolution is
really awesome and also the details
especially at where the where his fur is
you know you can see a bit more detail a
bit on his style than it being a flat
piece of uh like a prep piece of white
or flat piece of pink
so i find that the detail the quality of
it is for a2 print is astounding coming
out from a phone camera yeah it's not
too bad actually when we look at this i
mean obviously there is a little bit of
smudging here yeah obviously because
we've blown up and we're not you know
with the macro mode this is from the
macro mode of the camera system so it
won't probably be as sharp
or as you know on the screen it looks
great but when you blow it up to a2 size
you're going to see a difference in that
but let's go to the motorcycle for a
second because this was shot with the
main camera
uh in raw so what's your thoughts on
this shot right here i find it is um
it is still all right and the details i
still see very steep deep details and
even you know a little
stone stone chip there you know it can
be seen and the shadows the shadows
handle quite well because usually
for for
for i for cameras right phone cameras
usually it will be like it will be
smudgy in a lot of places even in these
areas right yeah so we're seeing so that
those tones of different blues yes
correct there it is yeah graduation
there the lightning bolts so because
your your bike has a lot of intricate
paintwork to it it's a lot i mean it's
you guys will see it in the video of
course probably better than what you'll
see here but it's really a lot of detail
and it's beautiful you can also see the
um distractions right here and and the
brake pad area the brake this area yeah
and this is like raw
so there's not uh there's nothing done
to it so
um it is just
resize and just print out this up the
size only that's all now here's the
here's the reality of it now while these
are good cameras right this is not going
to compare to let's say
a dslr mirrorless camera system yeah you
know 20 30 40 megapixels obviously
because that's a much larger sensor guys
so we're looking at a like a very small
sensor and a camera even though it's
large in the iphone 13 pro max it is
still significantly smaller than a full
frame or aps-c so while we're saying
this prints well
we're saying for a phone it looks good
right yes correct so now you said you're
going to do a composite for us yes i'm
going to do a composite based on the
story of my airbrush custom airbrush
artwork on my hair busa okay so let's
get to it
[Music]
so you've been recording so far with the
iphone 13 pro what are your thoughts on
it well it's hard to differentiate the
differences between the
iphone 13 pros and the iphone 12 pros
but
and i'm just talking about based on
video alone
but
cinematic mode is actually surprisingly
fun to use now
if you're gonna do quote-unquote
professional video
then you might want to use other camera
apps so throughout this video i actually
been
using both the default camera app and
filmic pro and i just find filmic pro
just has all the tools you need
for
making videos except cinematic mode
right except cinematic mode but here's
the catch
you can control the autofocus in filmic
pro
so you can actually play with the pull
focus
and still get pretty much the same
results it's more of a manual way of
doing things
but you get more fitness out of that as
well on top of that filmic pro does
shoot on log and flat
you can actually change
to 8-bit 10-bit dolby hdr if you wanted
to
filmic pro man so berries behind doing
some composites keeping it a surprise
bobby and he's not that cold but spotty
is doing something else
oh no
spotty behave
all right
it's done all right it's done all right
thanks so cool
we go film okay all all right so
now to reveal the composite
and the story of my hayabusa okay okay
so let's okay here it is
holy
wow
this is from the iphone yes this is for
the iphone 13 printer a2 composite with
the story of the hayabusa
so the front of my bike there's actually
a yang logo yeah which is where the bike
is sitting on
wow yeah it's sitting on and there's a
dragon so the the dragon comes in and
the thunder god that is on the bike
that's where the lightning comes in and
because this is a japanese concept
it's actually uh that's why i put a
japanese shrine
wow
yeah
can you find for the gig culture logo is
there a ghee culture looking yes yes
it's very subtle oh there it is
look at that
yeah that's cool man
yeah this is uh for you guys wow thank
you very much
dude that is legit check that out
that is legit
a composite yes with the iphone 13 pro
max uh image out of that okay so now i
got to ask you this in terms of the
technicalities right
how is it like to use an image like this
for a composite because usually you need
a lot of information a lot of detail
right yes correct so i find that um the
it is decent and the shadows and the
highlights are handled very well so i
can be able to manipulate without losing
the details that much yeah right
so even though i made it a bit darker um
it will it stays it doesn't smudge yeah
yeah because most of the time when it
comes to composite you have low quality
low quality photos the dark areas tend
to smudge it will turn to shadows it
means it's either it's black or gray it
does not have a gradient gray yeah so
that's the problem okay it's held up
pretty well then yes this one held out
really pretty well but it has to be
lighter well as well you know yeah the
lighting is cute
yes correct correct i mean i think
there's a lot of people when they see
the even when apple they do these great
ads for the iphone yeah yeah
they have really good lighting for these
guys and really good lighting allows low
iso more detail more sharpness but i
mean this looks impressive this is
beautiful barry thank you man thank you
so much
okay so final thoughts what are your
thoughts on it you think this camera's
legit or not yes the this camera is
legit for from my point of view i feel
that it is actually very very close to a
point and shoot we don't say mirrorless
but point and shoot right yeah the
quality of the point and shoot so
instead of carrying two one phone and
one point and shoot you can just use the
iphone 30. basically makes sense i mean
the point-and-shoot is pretty much i
mean we can say it's quote-unquote uh
it's moved on to the afterlife correct
right yeah the smartphone has taken over
that yeah and uh yeah the images are
fantastic man thank you so much because
i know this printing takes a lot of time
and it's a big expense on your part so
thank you very much for
and even this man that's that that's a
lot of work bro no problem no problem
thank you so much man and with that guys
does the iphone 13 pro max can it work
for printing the answer is yes yes it
can anyway those are our thoughts on the
iphone 13 pro max let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below
any questions you have ask away barry
thank you so much once again follow me
on monographer.com also put a link to
your ig as well
and just big thanks for taking all the
time to do all this man because printing
is not it's not cheap it's expensive
especially on a printer like that so
very really appreciate it very very much
no problem with that guys take care stay
safe follow us on facebook subscribe to
us on youtube and we will chat you the
next one take care
[Music]